I know a guy with a ponytail who got
test he got it surgically implanted two
test tablets or three in his ass in the
bottom of his ass crease for a week you
can't do any deep squats you can't do
anything working out it now is pumping
testosterone into his body he supposedly
in the next month or two is going to be
absolutely jacked and shredded he did
tell me he went from being able to do
two pull-ups to being able to do over 15
pull-ups in two weeks and they go to
surgery in his ass crack just so he can
increase his pull-ups here's the issue I
think he's a lot of issues every day yes
the the ponytail is the least of his
issue yeah yeah every day every day you
have to take an estrogen pill every day
as once you make the decision to take it
you have to continue it for the rest of
your life because if you don't then what
happens is your body sometimes doesn't
always get the message even when you
stop putting the testosterone tablets in
you that they have to start making
testosterone and you will go bald get
tits and develop a whole array of
problems
so so what I say worth it